people don't understand the feeling of
going to school you sit next to a friend
and that same night you hearing that
friend was murdered and you sitting in
that same best that next day he's not
there you realize he's not coming back
here
he didn't transfer to another school he
didn't he wasn't sick like he's not
coming back period I'm Taylor Oakes
and these are conversations about
defining one's relationship to blackness
and how that defines their America
Wade Jamar same question I asked
everybody first on this series when did
you realize that being black was
different from being white playing
basketball always gave me the
opportunity to see different places be
around different places and I think
first time I thought I was in ninth
grade we would we drove out like two
hours away to the school this white
community and I seen for the first time
how different their schools were
facilities just everything about that
culture was like night and day from us
and they it used to from then on they
used to make me question like dan why
why they stuff better why they had this
better why did he talk better or why'd
he dress better or why so many questions
came about you know and as I continue to
get older and get older I seen a
separation from you know privilege
privilege to you know where we came from
you know getting everything you know
feeling like leftovers and making it
work you know that's when I first
started noticing it when you noticed it
that disparity and like just the huge
huge is different how did that make you
feel it leaves you numb for a while for
me personally because you was just
trying to figure it out you know and as
I became older and started to see things
different
you know it just always left a question
mark with a lot of things you know and
some I never even told people I allowed
was when I went to college even though I
with the SC that was 15 20 minutes away
from content I had a culture shock like
it was it was the first time that I was
really because consistently around you
know white people and you seen everybody
with laptops talking what a different
type of binocular like the slain was out
like it was so anything that was so
different from my culture and it was
kind of intimidating you know it's kind
of intimidating because that was like
the first time where I'm in an
environment that that didn't feel like
me to feel comfortable and I felt like
they was looking at me differently other
than just being an athlete you know and
that that was kind of a frustrating that
just made that I had to used to in
college how did you get used to it
it took a while I didn't live I didn't
stay on campus for my first three four
months of college this is you not stay
on campus because of the culture yeah it
was just too much of a culture shock
like being around it and it was like it
was like it was a feeling that is so
hard to explain
because I grew up in his urban
environment and I felt like that was the
norm to going to that I couldn't imagine
being going to University of Kentucky
being from LA you know being left out
trying to figure this out on my own but
um it was rough it was it was extremely
rough and I just want to stay in my
element as long as possible so I felt
comfortable being on campus really so
when you kind of decided to go back to
campus and be around you know everybody
that was on campus do you feel nervous
you feel you don't be accepted like
what's the hesitation there yeah being
nervous not accepting not
having what they had not you know you
know not knowledgeable of the freedom of
movement that they had you know people
always think it's cool for us as
athletes just be an athlete but at the
end day we we people we human beings
that we we want to be accepted that way
so for me not to be able to comprehend
with a different culture and knowing
that my culture had looked down upon in
a certain type of way was was
frustrating so I tried to wait for me
for a long time you know I wonder if we
underestimate the challenge that black
athletes have going to at universities
and honestly I don't know if I ever
really sat and thought about it in that
way because I'm seeing so much of it
from my experience but a lot of these
athletes that go and play sports are
coming from areas where they probably
have not interacted with a lot of white
people right right you know and I think
I think that definitely goes on
unnoticed because it's it's it's one of
those things to where it's it's just
College in itself it's hard for for us
being minorities coming from we come
from - all of a sudden we sitting in
these intimidating classrooms with what
a different type of culture that don't
know us don't get you get us you know
and it's it's never been it's just
always been an accepting factor not
feeling like we was always accepting
unless we was a athlete or some someone
of suddenly instead of just being looked
at as a person yeah and I think you said
a key thing that I think is important
it's not about you accepting them it's
that you feel like they won't accept you
right those two things really really
aren't the same you know I was really
glad that I am able to talk to you
because honestly when I saw that you
protested in California you were super
heavy on my heart because I thought
about when I interviewed you for my show
we were talking about death and you said
that you were almost desensitized to it
the idea of people dying was something
that had made you numb cuz you had seen
it so much so what is it like for you to
see black people be murdered by police
is it's a thing that I like even with
this last situation no rest and peace is
George Roy the when that situation
happened and you know I've started
seeing all the protests and all you know
the looting you just start to see
everything transpire
I'm gonna call my mom one night I
actually I said I was I think I was
three years old when the whites where I
had to when bribed me King beaten happy
and I just want to ask her how what was
I doing at three years old you know cuz
especially me I have a three-year-old
daughter and a seven-year-old daughter
and I remember one day I had the news on
I'm seeing all the fires and all the
buildings on fire and I see my kids
sitting there and they really not
knowing and understanding what's going
on so I put myself in their shoes and I
remember I called my mom and I asked
myself what was going on and you know it
gave me a perspective on what type of
lifestyle I was living and grew up in of
that being the norm and it was more so
like yeah you sitting there playing but
you know so much after that transpired
and became worse and worse in my
lifetime - made me feel these senses
ties to certain tragedies because you
know you got to keep going you got to
keep moving you got to keep pushing you
know and it was one of those things
where you know they didn't have to
figure it out but it was more so like
yeah that's what the police do so
growing up it was more so me knowing and
feeling like oh that's a norm or the
police or they just can't wait to catch
a black black man doing something wrong
so they could do this tool to you you
know I mean this cameras and all this
filming stuff was going on it was always
like growing up was was taught to me was
like by all means if you see the
please let them pass by then go about
your business you know he gave me an
uncomfortable factor because growing up
it was so normal to think and fear the
police because you didn't want to end up
like in a situation like that with them
yeah as this has happened I think people
are seeing that black people aren't
surprised that it's happening because we
grow up we grew up with these talks of
what you do when you see a cop and that
a lot of cops will hurt you right so it
isn't an element of surprise it's more
of like oh this happen again right and I
think a lot of trauma comes with that
you know knowing that if a white person
sees a cop they feel safe yeah I don't
think I've ever seen a cop and been like
oh like I'm safe I'm like oh I got to go
in another Lane you know what I mean and
and that's a conversation that I think
I'm I'm glad as being had now just the
way that we all grow up in a
relationship to Authority and knowing
that the way when I say Authority I mean
cuffs but I also mean white people and
the privilege and power that I people
have our relationship to that authority
is kind of coming to the forefront
mm-hmm you also said something in our
interview that you had to grow up very
quickly and you had to understand things
that a kid isn't supposed to understand
what are some things that you were
referring to death you know early on uh
five six Europe years old I lost my
school to gang violence I lost another
uncle to gang violence
I'm never going to funerals in you know
seeing my mother cry countless nights
countless days to where you know I'm
ever one year I mama with 1520 funerals
you know and it got to a point to where
to this day I
I don't like fuels because they were so
they came up so frequently who do my
youth you know and that was something to
where people don't understand the
feeling of going to school and you
sitting next to a friend and they that
same night you hearing that friend was
murdered
and you sitting in that same desta next
day he's not there and you realize he's
not coming back here
he didn't transfer to another school he
didn't he wasn't sick like he's not
coming back period you know to deal with
that and in a comprehend with that I
think people really don't understand
unless you go through it how hard it is
and they put you in his face to where
either it could break you down or are
you you gonna build up this wall inside
of you that gives you the extra strength
to keep pushing they just want to make
it out but not being at that position
anymore to keep dealing with this type
of feeling you know I lost my best
friend in high school it's a murder you
know all these things to where I haven't
even had a developed mental yet and I'm
comprehending the worst thing possible
that a kid could go through so with that
it is definitely something that that
that definitely leaves a leaves a scar
inside of you for a long time so it was
tough like I said you know I've been an
advocate for no depression and a lot of
that stems from my from my childhood
things that I never addressed and you
know I think at this point of time going
on in the world it's so much going on
it's so much it's definitely
traumatizing
you know we turn on the news and you see
so much negativity you saying the police
do this or it's over and over and over
and you see innocent people being killed
over and over and over you know it's
just it's just a time that an
opportunity for us to all come together
not just celebrities people in general
and in voice
how they feel in their opinion and
really make a change you talk about the
trauma like turning on the TV and saying
bad things and you're looking at your
phone and saying but you'll be murdered
what I've been talking to black people
I've really just been asking like are
you okay right right so I mean are you
okay really yeah it's tough I in my mind
it's like how how can we be okay you
know and I ask myself something up today
on TV and I was just like it was a
newscaster she was um talking to a black
man and he was expressing his
frustration and through his frustration
you know he was using cuss we're seeing
in there and the newscaster on TV was
like uh-uh we gotta cut him off he using
200 profanity and in my mind I'm sitting
here watching I'm like but you could
pick up your phone and we sing officers
killing unarmed people so you you you
you undermining how the way this man
express his frustration because he tired
of seeing people die but nothing and it
was like really that just shows me right
there you don't know what it's like to
walk in our shoes to be a black person
you know I mean you worried about him
saying a cuss word you should be more
worried about being able to go to your
phone and seeing so many people killed
for not like that's what's that's the
type of stuff that trips me up you know
I mean it's like how can we be okay with
that when you seeing that every day or
you don't see people sympathizing what
it's like to be black you know me my
absolutely that's my frustration and I
don't think my frustration and change
until people could get some sort of idea
and sympathize with that and start to
begin help with us as a collective group
that's the only way you know I mean if
you don't do that it's gonna be that
frustration it's gonna be that
aggression you know because that's all
that's all we know especially when it's
something that we passionate about and
we passionate about our people so we got
to take care of that and the best way to
do it if we all come together and do it
with every race and you make a good
point with this white woman's react
- the black man is white people cannot
police how we feel right now right not
only because they'll never understand it
mm-hmm but because the only thing that
we have to give is the emotion it's the
emotion that's carrying us through it's
the emotion that makes protest
successful it's the emotion that brings
change so the more a white person feels
uncomfortable with how we express
ourselves it's really just them saying
they're uncomfortable with the movement
right right yeah we need that it's it's
our biggest power right now
is each other and how we're looking
after each other and how those emotions
manifest so I understand why I'd be
frustrated to hear that I'm frustrating
I appreciated even here that a woman
tried to police his his words when we're
trying to change people's actions you
know the words are the base level of it
so yeah I think a lot of black people
like you know I had a thought when
someone asked me if I was okay I thought
was like if I'm killed will the person
be arrested yes this is all these
questions that everybody that I see acts
are legitimate questions that we still
cannot get an answer to but you wonder
why we frustrated get upset and want to
question our actions you know like oh
like this not not just with this
situation a year ago ten years ago this
is been going over you know I mean it's
been going on I grew up singing I'm 30
years old I couldn't imagine how my dad
is from Louisiana like he grew up in
wholesale segregated south and
everything so up into I was 12 years old
he used to take me to Louisiana with all
the time like once every summer so I was
12 years old and I didn't really
understand it and I got older and I
started to see the segregation of how it
was in the South in the obstacle my dad
had to go to have a deal with have to
slight all these things and I used to
always question like me being from the
city being a city boy
I said hey going through the country but
I was one of the lessons that showed me
so much as a kid because it was his
height
I can imagine growing up a night I
couldn't imagine growing up yeah
[Music]
we think we think is crazy now is this
our parenting grandparents would do so
much and now I look at it like this is
the ultimate opportunity for us to to do
something incredible like incredible and
really make a change yeah how has your
mental health been throughout this um
I've been I've been managing that I
think I think for me just being more
mature and understanding how to reach
out and and speak to other individuals
that may not know how to handle yeah
thanks it's been helpful for me you know
before I used to close in and become
sheltered and kind of steer away and shy
away from everything you know and try to
figure it out on my home I think more so
for me I've been more so when I lend a
hand
and that's being therapeutic for me
others listen to me and I give I give
whatever experience and whatever
honestly that I'm dealing with and try
to share that you know I think that's
been definitely beneficial for me
especially without having no basketball
all this time yeah there's some that's
been helpful for me one thing that I
think you know I admire about you and a
lot of the black men that I end up
speaking to is you find a lot of power
and vulnerability and understanding that
emotion can really help you but there's
also a conversation to be had about
black men growing up feeling as though
they can't be emotional right was that
your experience and if it was your
experience how did you shift away from
that okay I grew up in Compton it was it
was it was a tough time and I
it was a tough time because every single
day was worse than the day previously
you know it would such a normal it came
it became such a normal normal time you
know I talked to a lot of my friends
that grew it and we really sit back and
trip on how crazy the times were but we
didn't look at it like that because
that's all we knew ya know for me what
helped me was when when I had my first
daughter that that showed me a sense of
empathy compassion loving care and a
whole element of something that I never
I never really had you know always had
it within my mother but my mother was my
mother is she's one of the strongest
women I ever came across you know so she
always had that you know my grandma was
loving and caring but she was always
like I mess up guys now you know yeah
trust me I know you me know when I when
I when I when I got older and I had my
daughter and it was somebody who needed
to lean on me it gave me that sense of
loving care empathy and it kind of
knocked down and softened the wall that
I that I had built up for so long you
know so that helped me you know but it
definitely should be other ways and and
we should feel okay especially when you
know you you you made it through the
rough times in life to understand that
you're a man you never never have to
doubt or question yourself it should be
okay to be be vulnerable because we need
it missiny we meet absolutely absolutely
and I think mentally we need it the
world needs it everybody needs it you
talked about your daughters how are you
going to talk to your daughters about
being black I just sounded my beautiful
you know one thing since day one thought
I could talk always expressed to my
daughters understand how beautiful they
are intelligent they are how you know
confident they should be how never late
nothing
negative knock them down so you know so
many so many positive that that
especially a black moment need to hear
on a daily basis so the entire life is
they got nothing from that for me like
that's all I give them every single day
so they understand that with some BS
come my way they don't even faze them
know I'll be strong black women
understand what you need to do how you
need to do it but it's gonna be
obstacles that you're gonna need to face
and these this just make sure you assess
it understand it and proceed with
however you need to proceed with it with
you know and just giving them an
understanding of that no so long as they
knowledgeable of understanding the
wrongs and rights of life you know I
feel like I'll be okay once they become
older older black women upon his earth
yeah absolutely
I obviously saw those very powerful
images of you and Kendrick Lamar and
Russell Westbrook out protesting and
Compton and I was able to talk to
Kendrick about it but he's like you know
now I want action I want to figure out
what I can do to help you know past
protesting but just seeing you guys out
there I think meant a lot to so many
people but how did that come to be
like how did you three get together and
say okay let's protest with me here walk
me through that
Oh many people that see it it was it was
a couple fighting about a week ago it
was a couple of cops in Compton that had
beat up a young black male one night it
was all over the news and it was one of
those moments to where I call it I
actually call my high school coach and
we was talking the body I was like let's
figure out something we can do for the
city you know
the unite the city because at that time
captain had had a protest yet you know
major major parts of LA had and I just
told him this just another opportunity
for us to be able to come together and
and show you know one of the key cities
and lay that you know we United in in a
statement gathered um I fell asleep I
woke up the next day my high school
coach had talked to the mayor next thing
you know we put the protest together to
put it out I'm City to everybody I know
and we went to the protest you know Russ
Russ is being when a close friends a
mine since I could I could remember and
he always been advocate when it comes to
things like this his father his parents
and everybody you know it's been one of
those one of those things and Kendrick
I mean he's from counseling you know so
it's it's it's it was a no-brainer
knowing you know he was gonna come and
support and you know kid you really see
Kendrick these days yeah for him to come
out and show that and get the
inspiration it's great because Kendrick
has been an inspiration for you know
this dis generation coming kids growing
up in confidence so you know it was a
beautiful moment um wanted one moment I
cherish for the rest of my life me and
they would be a part of that and giving
whatever pilot Sydney inspiration I
could to it ya know it's it's very
powerful for people to see those that
they look at often and look to often you
know protesting so no thank you
absolutely for doing that I put out a
report recently talking about the zoom
calls NBA players have been on I know
you guys have already done one and
there's about to be another zoom call
just about what you all can do to unify
and take a stand I assume you have but
have you been on those zoom calls privy
to them and just tell me what they have
been like very intense I mean people
know us for being athletes but don't
understand how competitive we are when
it comes to other other things and how
vocal were intelligent
every single got it that's in his
profession is and every everyone those
guys has a incredible idea passion will
to want to put
foot forward to making a change you know
every step away you seen guys been doing
it for four years now you know God is
like Melo CP Brian the way it's all
these guys that's that's coming together
and even teaching and bringing up the
young guys to understand how to go about
this thing so it's definitely been a
passionate thing and in passionate
conversations on how to push this thing
forward
you know whenever you get a collective
guys that's the ultimate competitors and
put their minds to something I really
believe some great won't come out of it
I've heard that Kyrie has been very
vocal on this and leading a lot of
discussions are there any other guys
that you have like kind of seen emerge
as leaders in this right yeah yeah you
know a lot of guys that's that's that's
quiet stated themselves you know they
they step in stepping forward
you know putting a foot for and I
understanding like this is opportunity
for us to you know really show who we
really are and you see you know like I
said we know how a lot of us are but the
world don't and seeing these guys step
forward showing that true characters
it's going to be even more amazing I'm
sure there has to be many more
conversations but just in your opinion
what do you think will happen and what
do you want to happen um my opinion I
think something that hasn't been done to
do you know all our leaders that set the
groundwork to changing you know equality
and justice just everything I think it's
finally finally gonna be able to switch
in lean to the right way it's a fairness
to how I should have always been you
know and I think you're definitely gonna
see the world come together in all the
people that's against this be exposed
and be outnumbered by by all the
greatness that everybody else trying to
do for the next generation so I really
truly believe that it will be a change
and it won't be another 10 20 30 years
of this madness because of the power of
the people stepping forward with
undeniably poof like you know it's it's
nightmare in front of you like beard for
us to understanding and take advantage
of and run with and put it out there to
be fair and not I truly believe it I
truly believe it Popovich has been such
a voice throughout this and always is he
always gives his thoughts on politics
social justice racial injustice what
conversations does he have with you guys
internally not just about racial issues
but the role that white people play in
those issues man since since day one I
got with the Spurs pop was the most
conscious person when it comes to
society that I came across especially a
white person you know
[Music]
I had opportunity to play with Dwayne
Casey that's from Kentucky he always use
Express I grew up in the south
I was a segregation was and everything
and he always used to speak about well
you know that injustice and all those
things that came with you know growing
up back in a day and I learned so much
from him and the flipside to go play
with a coach a white coach that feels
the same way like he was a black man of
understanding the unfairness how much
things need to change
it's part man it's been so many days
where we had come in and we think we had
failed and Papa cities down and show us
something about crooked cop or a man
losing its life for nothing how messed
up the system is how just all these
things that's been going on he'd been
making us aware of this even if he
wasn't paying attention are are are as
passionate as the next person he put it
on the forefront every single day it
wasn't a day that would buy what pop
does not you know so it's not surprising
me when I see him speak up and say these
things behind closed doors he do this on
a daily basis to show us how come how
messed up of a society that we live in
and how its own us to to change it you
know in your team meetings would be
video yeah as he will he will show a
clip or whatever a topic is of something
and it will put life in perspective for
for you you know and it's one of the
most incredible things that that a lot
of people wouldn't know unless you play
for him that it it definitely goes
beyond basketball and to see a white man
of his stature he'd be the first one to
jump out there and he you don't care
what no one else thinks he speaks the
truth
and you see it in his words you know you
got a got a love and respect the
individual like that yeah well when it
comes to basketball obviously a lot of
the talk has been do players even want
to play
with all of this injustice happening in
your opinion and what you've gathered
from the calls what makes people nervous
about sitting out and what has that
conversation been I think the
conversation is it's such a tricky time
that nobody nobody expected our could
foresee with the pandemic with with you
know everything that's been going on
it's just been it's just been a tricky
tricky year so far you know and it's so
many mixed feelings and in terms of you
know how different different and
difficult is gonna be attempting to play
with everything that's going on that's
bigger than us bigger than bigger than
basketball bigger than just playing a
game you know so it's hard to shift all
of a sudden without playing the sports
we love with everything going on - all
of a sudden our focus and our mindset
has been towards you know trying to make
a change and make a difference so it's
definitely it's definitely mixed
emotions I think - we just trying to get
to a place of a settlement of
understanding like okay where can we put
our energy to and still be focused on
other other things at the same time
because we you know we still not sure
how it's going to work when we go to our
land oh you know right people so many
question marks of the not knowing and
not feeling all the way comfortable so
you know I'm just through human nature
it definitely be hesitation there you
know because you just don't know you
know it's not like is going back to
regular we playing in our arenas we're
doing this now you saying we've been
here for this amount of time locked in
this place alright now you gotta kind of
guys down there understanding all that's
going on how we gonna do this are we
away from my family so like I said
there's some mixed emotions but I know
for a fact guys want to play basketball
you know it's just it's just trying to
get to all these emotions of things
that's going on well lastly
I and all of these with the same
question and that is words mean
different things to different people
how do you define America being black
you have to be strong enough to bring up
the next person behind you to be even
greater to make life better for anyone
to come after you
that's what America means to me being
black putting yourself in a position I'd
be able to pull up somebody below you to
do something better than you to make
life much more better for the next
person that's that's how I look at it
[Music]